earlier this week i started a full-time
role at amazon web services after being
an
intern for eight months many students
have been reaching out asking questions
like
hey lucy i'm interested in applying for
an amazon internship
what was your application process like
or i want to be a solutions architect
can you tell me more about what the role
entails at aws and how i can land a job
like this
so i thought i'd make a series of videos
to try and answer some of these
questions
if you're new here my name is lucy and i
make videos all about tech
career and student advice i'm going to
be breaking down this video into three
parts so first i want to talk about my
journey into aws as an intern
the whole end-to-end process of applying
online doing interviews and receiving
the offer
i then want to talk about how to get
that first interview and how to stand
out as an applicant
and finally i'm going to be going
through some interview tips and how you
can show your best self during the
interviews
i've also included time stamps in the
description below so
feel free to skip around to whatever
section you might find the most useful
let's get into it okay so now i'm going
to talk about my experience with
applying to aws
i actually applied to edibles twice one
in 2019
and once in 2020 so i thought it would
be best to structure this video by
answering these three questions because
these were three questions that
i was always curious about before doing
my amazon interviews
so first question is what are the
different stages of the application
process
and i guess a typical sort of
application process would be
first you submit your resume online and
then you do
phone interviews followed by
face-to-face interviews
and then getting the offer so i really
wanted to break this down though because
um one thing i wanted to know which
brings me on to the second question was
what were the interviews like so what
sort of questions did they ask
how did they sort of structure it and i
guess it really depends on the role
because
sometimes if you apply for a software
developer intern role
they might be asking more technical
questions so throughout the interview
process
a big emphasis was on the amazon's 14
leadership principles
so for example one of the leadership
principles is deliver results
so if they want to try and see when
you've sort of developed results
in the past they might ask you about any
previous experience that you had whether
that be
in a university society or through
volunteering and the third question is
what happens if i don't get in if you
don't get in that's completely okay
i want to leave you with two pieces of
advice first of all rejection is
redirection
as long as you know what to improve on
for the future for the first time if you
don't end up making it through to the
final stages
perhaps you can ask for interview
feedback or you can do
a reflection on what you think went well
what do you think didn't go well the
second thing
is when they say no unfortunately you
haven't made it through as a candidate
it doesn't mean no it means no not for
now
so think of that as an opportunity to
grow
and don't let that stop you from
applying in the future so i
ended up applying twice and only ended
up getting
the offer the second time around so the
main takeaway is
don't let these rejections stop you and
turn these notes
into no not for now okay moving on to
the second part of this video
how do you stand out as an applicant so
there's so many external factors that
come with this because you can never
really predict the outcome of your
interview
what you can do though is to control
what you can control
and what i mean by this is to tailor
your resume
attend networking events and get
different perspectives from people who
are in the company
perfecting your resume is really about
tailoring it to
the job that you're applying for i think
students fall into the trap
of sometimes applying to hundreds of
different positions
thinking that at least one company would
reply to them
and although that might be the case it's
much more efficient for you to
focus on maybe five or six roles that
you really want
across different companies and really
pinning down on making sure that
you go through that process of getting
to know the company
getting to know a few people inside the
company and
when it comes to applying for the role
trying to get a referral
so that your application can stand out
more and if you think about it in the
past it might be really hard
you might have to attend networking
events that maybe
your university doesn't even offer you
might have to travel to another
university to
talk to a representative from a company
but nowadays with things like linkedin
and different company online events you
can actually still interact with
representatives
from different companies without having
to travel very far because it's still
or at home so this is something that i
would really encourage students to
leverage
using linkedin reaching out to different
people in the company
maybe setting up coffee chats with them
to understand their role
and if they're too busy don't have the
time to maybe can ask for a quick chat
just over text
and then once it comes time for you to
submit an application
i guess you have more of an
understanding of what the role is
what the company does and what the
company values in its candidates
in this final part of the video i'm
going to share some interview tips on
what has worked for me
and what i picked up on after doing
dozens of interviews throughout my
university degree
so what i wanted to start off with this
is something that's
more specific to amazon it's to prepare
two or three examples for each amazon
leadership principle
so as i mentioned before there's 14
leadership principles that
amazon really focuses on during the
interview process
so by preparing two or three interview
examples um
this this would involve so for example
if a leadership principal
was to earn trust then you would think
about two or three times in the past
where you've sort of earned trust with a
customer and trust with
maybe students that you worked with in
group assignments and coming up with
like
two or three solid examples can really
help prepare you for the interview
my second tip and this applies to all
sorts of interviews not just amazon ones
it's to go back to the job description
really dissect it and find important
keywords
and by this i mean look at the preferred
qualifications
look at what the job requires what sort
of person that they're looking for
and typically for interviews especially
for interns they don't look
at how much previous experience you've
had particularly
but i guess mourn your attitude towards
learning
towards being flexible having a growth
mindset things like that
and a lot of that attitude can really be
shown by the amount you prepare for the
interview so
if you um just go into the interview not
really understanding what the company
does what the mission
of the company is then it's really hard
for the interviewer to you know be
convinced that
you'll be a good fit for the role so
that brings me to
my third point and my third point is to
really do your research on the company
so if you look in the news anything
where
the company was brought up you could
look at the company's history so
how it was first established what its
vision is for the next coming years
you don't necessarily have to mention
everything that you've researched
in the interview but it's really helpful
if the interviewer ever wants to
dive deeper on their motivations for
joining the company um and when they do
you can mention things like articles
that you've read
um things that you've seen on the news
stuff like that that would really help
as well
and this wraps up my video thanks so
much for watching i hope you got
something out of it please give it a
like if you did
and subscribe for more tech student and
career related advice videos
please leave a comment down below if you
have any questions bye for now